[Music]
now first remember that story that we
did about chicago about the water polo
team
oh okay well guess what
austin is getting ready to expand a
program that saves lives on the water
thanks for joining us tonight i'm lisa
hughes and i'm christina rex paula is
off the city launched a program to help
teach more people of color to swim wbz's
katrina kincaid looks at some of the
barriers this program works to overcome
teaching people of color to swim
what is this lately with them i have no
idea
according to usa swimming 70 percent of
black people don't know how to swim i
think haitians do
some of those initial barriers was
access
okay
access to an actual [ __ ] [ __ ]
mulatto sideshow bob over here telling
us lady what's up with that hair man she
was trying to get in the pool but every
time she tried to get in the pool she
kept walking into a rake
pool access to
maybe going to beaches and being
comfortable and being welcomed in those
environments
it's 2022.
do not tell me black people are not
welcome at beaches i saw the videos at
south beach
seriously panama
are they still doing the
it's 2022 are they still oh black people
are swimming
[Music]
it's
it's so [ __ ] patronizing
the swim safely partnership provides
free swim lessons at boston area ymcas
especially for people who historically
have faced economic what does that mean
no no no which that's
the sentence should have ended there
right the ymca offers free swim lessons
period right what about but especially
for black people what does that even
mean does that mean that do they teach
them how to swim harder or better like i
i don't understand what this means
they are so mine their minds are blown
the black people are getting in water
and logistic barriers to swim safety
training according to the cdc drowning
deaths for black people are 1.5 times
higher than white people and
water is now racist water has always
hold on the s the astronaut give always
has been
[Laughter]
water is now disproportionately killing
black people
so you're telling me water
water is like other black people
[Laughter]
no water still doesn't kill as many
black people as other black people oh
god well they didn't drown it was it was
mutual combat
by the way you think they count every
time somebody in chicago was shot and
thrown into a lake
black children ages 10 to 14 it's 3.6
times higher when you look at drowning
specifically in swimming pools that
number jumps to 7.6 times higher i've
heard okay wait a little children
drowning in swimming pools
could one speculate
that
that might have more to do with a lack
of supervision
right it's here's a great example it's
like the chance of drowning goes up a
thousand percent if you're at william
shatner's house like that's how you're
tommy lee's house or tommy lee's house
hotels beaches various community centers
literally were unwelcoming to black
people
2022
and i think over time
you believe that and you just don't go
and you don't oh so let me guess so the
reason why people are not as good at
basketball as black people is because
over time they didn't let them play
basketball that's what it is right they
weren't welcome
it's not because of the entire hot the
higher thighs
mikey the greek over here needs to relax
because they would breed the the big
black
dude he was the best
don't swim then there's the issue of
swim caps
what
what
are you good let me guess i haven't
watched this
frozen you know i haven't watched it she
sent it to me i refuse to watch it till
the show
are they about to make and i hope this
isn't true are they about to say that
swim caps are also racist
it seems like it i only made it so far
and then all right you know well that's
kind of like a kind of like a black
person in a pool let's see
so
i used to have very long hair but now
it's just right here and even with this
one you have to find one that works for
you these are regular swim caps they're
made out of latex but they're not always
the best for people who use a lot of
products in their hair a bigger hair
braids or weaves but these are soul caps
is what the program uses
they just said these are soul caps this
is what the program uses so if remember
they teach everyone to swim so imagine
you're the one white guy that goes in
there for swim lessons and you have to
wear a soul cap
oh thank you this is this is bait right
this has to be bait they're [ __ ] with
us again burst they're doing it again
if you want more um examples of soul
caps uh check show links thank you ken
okay
i am i'm going to show links as we speak
let's see here
oh okay so that link okay
do you want some soul caps
soul caps
so these are swimming caps for black
people
right apparently yes
cool yeah because we needed that i think
that was something that was really
important uh hold on let me keep uh
sure it is
they're bigger and better for people of
different backgrounds and different hair
textures by the way did you see how far
around she she had to talk an extra 20
seconds instead of saying these swim
caps are for black people
it's that's not a racist statement
either
it's okay to say that right
is it racist to say this swim cap is for
black people here
i mean i would imagine making a company
that produces swim caps for black people
is probably not very profitable
is the picture and show links uh
offensive
all right let's see
no yeah that's the one here see that's
the one here on the right where it's a
soul cap group this one here it looks
like it looks like uh
if like if this was a movie i would 100
think this was one of those conehead
aliens
100
there's no way you could prove this
would this would be like in the movie
coneheads what they would have in the
pool as it actually wasn't the daughter
of swimmer or a diver in that movie if i
remember correctly she was something
with her
okay
hair texture
many many many times about this is you
know here's some shampoos you can use or
this is you know maybe have your hair
this way so you can put a cap just by
growing up i was told by my racist uncle
that the water just beads off is was
that a lie
no i'm not saying i don't believe that
i'm just saying what i was told by my
racist uncle
and does the water stay the same color
or it doesn't come off okay i don't know
it's a little oilier because of the hair
product
bird african islands surrounded by water
erika herself didn't learn how to swim
until 11th grade in america now she's a
well-known swimming wait you lived in an
island surrounded by water and you
didn't learn how to swim until you came
to america
seems odd instructor at the roxbury ymca
swimming is a life skill i appreciate
that i know how to do that and i've
tried to teach as many people as i can
the program originally had space for 300
children and adults to participate they
just received more funding and will now
expand to serve 600. katrina kincaid
bro these are things that aren't real
issues but isn't it weird how news
organizations always around the same
time have these coordinated stories like
why is there more than one story about
black people learning to swim on the
news right
oh uh
social engineering
yeah i guess